good afternoon councillors ladies and
gentlemen
i'll welcome you along to this
extraordinary meeting of council to
consider our submissions to the
long-term plan 2021-2031
we have two apologies uh this afternoon
councillor nick grant and councillor
bulger are unable to be with us
so would somebody like to move those
apologies be sustained please uh move
councillor guarding second
council mcdonald all those in favor
please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
okay so um we have a process to work
through this afternoon and we've had
154 submitters 19 have
indicated they'd like to speak to you
this afternoon
some have again since that time
withdrawn so we have a schedule that
we'll work through
quite deliberately and purposefully
there's 10 minutes allowed for each
speaker
the only request for extra time that
i've had has come from
mr gardiner and i've said to him that
depending on how we're going
um time wise at that stage uh i may
allow a little bit extra time
but otherwise we'll stick pretty close
to to what we have scheduled we have
a long afternoon to get through and a
lot of
very worthy submissions to to consider
before i asked the chief executive to
just give his opening
comments are there any particular
questions from
councillors i guess probably the only
thing that i would like to
reinforce and particularly for
councillors who may be
entering into this progress process for
the first time
and this is an opportunity for the
submitters to speak to us
and it is not an opportunity for
debating with submitters
it's an opportunity to understand
exactly what they're saying
and requesting and in that
situation there is an opportunity to
question
a submitter but it is really around
getting clarity about what they're after
as opposed to ending and entering into a
debate
so if everybody abide by that rule then
i think we'll get through things pretty
quickly
okay any uh counselor grant yeah sure
worship just for
uh clarification i am the representative
go district council representative on
the
uh first submarighan district since
james theatre trust
okay thank you thanks for declaring that
are there any other comments or
questions
counselors want to make before we start
just to clear the uh
in regards to james just a family member
that's employed by
sir james theatre okay thank you
uh if there's not mr chief executive do
you want to make any opening comments at
all
not really you worship for the staff's
point of view
we really like extras in a movie we will
be here just to take notes
and observe the proceedings and then
we'll the staff will compile a report
that will go to the council meeting next
wednesday where the
that's the deliberative meeting where
the council will be invited to make
decisions on the issues raised by
submitters both
here to today and in the written
submissions that we have already
received
okay so um we'll move on to
the first submission and that is indeed
a submission from goran district's
um james theatre trust and a submission
under the name of craig mcintyre so um
if i could ask the submitters when their
time has
arrived if they can come forward and use
the the table at the front here and
ask them to use the microphone as well
we are live streaming today and
for people who are watching externally
then they need to be able to hear what
you're saying
so unless the microphone is working and
you're using it they won't know what
you're saying
the same goes for counsellors as well
please remember to use your
microphone when when you are asking a
question
so craig if you're ready would you want
to come forward um is the microphone
there will be a um a ring of a bell at
eight minutes
and and another ring at ten minutes just
to keep everybody on task with
with time so so welcome along
and the floor is yours
i think you can take it for read and
i'll say this to all submitters you can
take it
as read that counselors have read and
understand the submissions at this point
okay thank you your worship emir
councillors good afternoon
i'm here today representing the gore and
districts and james theatre trust
for those that don't know me my name is
craig mcintyre and i'm the current
chairman of the trust
helping with the presentation today is
yvonne bannerman
who is also a trustee and phil conroy
who's the project manager
and he's from chan shelton company in
wellington
in 1936 the st james theater was opened
in 1987 keredonian decided that they
would sell the theater
the gore operatic society gore host
lions school roacher club
and the gorbarra council came together
and
agreed on the need to retain a theatre
for the benefit of gore and the district
community
the gore and districts and james theatre
trust was established
to own the theatre the mandate is to
ensure that the theatre remains
a community for remains for the
community
responsible for the capital expenditure
the purchase of was funded by the gore
operatic society
a 45-year operational lease was granted
to the gore operatic society
the theatre operations committee was
established and they
are responsible for the operations
and the maintenance costs
the initial work's completed the main
auditorium was reconfigured
to enable stage a stage for a live
performance
the basic dressing room space was
created back
of house to support live performances
the foyer was reconfigurated and front
of house toilets increased
a second small cinema was created
the theater was reroofed tendency space
is created
the green room cath being a
long-standing
tendency and also at the moment the
sushi shop
these works were enabled through the
success success of fundraising
support of the of local companies
and volunteer areas undertaken by the
gore operatic society members
as well as the gore lines club and
rotary club members
the initial works enabled the theater to
become more than just a movie theater
it enabled a community buy-in and
the retention of the theatre while
limited in its facilities
it began to encourage and support other
community uses
the combination of cinema
live theatre cafe and toilets
establish the theater as being more than
just a destination
in 1998 the trust identified a need
to upgrade the facility for life
performance
and address health and safety issues
that existed
a concept design established in 1998
that we had to seismically strengthen
the building
and that left the trust with a task of
raising some 2.7 million
over the next 10 years which it did
including a 250 000 contribution from
gore district council
the construction was finally undertaken
in 2008 2009
um it was a mix of local contractors all
but four were from the district and gore
and volunteers and that was delivered on
time and within budget
and actually extended the scope of works
that we started out with day one
um that delivered the auditorium stage
house back of house facilities
to a nbs of the day and
uh of 65 at il3
um in in 2012 the cinema was
uh plant was upgraded to digital
and over that time the trust raised not
only 3.75 million dollars
to achieve that it also was successful
by virtue of the fact of the tens if not
hundreds of thousands
of voluntary hours that were put in by
its members
so as a result of that the theater
attracts
people like the royal new zealand ballet
the new zealand symphony orchestra
court theatre in fact today we have um
neil diamond in the theater so we gore
has become part of the new zealand
touring circuit
which is bringing the cultural and
financial benefits into the district
it also enhances the community's the
community uses production values
and as you'll see from one of those
photographs in there the quality of that
production which is mamma mia
was second to none
it also by lifting its
lifting the uses has ensured that the
income stream
for the operations and maintenance is
able to be funded
by its operation and that's pretty
unique
the next stages for the trust are to
take the building
in its current state and
complete the seismic strengthening and
for that we have to strengthen
a wall in the foyer we have to create a
lift to address the issues raised by
council's compliance officers of
non-accessibility for persons with
disabilities
we need to add accessible toilets
to the foyer and generally do a
refurbishment
of those as well as re-roof the
cinema small cinema the project budget
is 1.2 million dollars plus gst
so we have raised 637
000 that has not been an easy feat
um we've got a shortfall of 600 653
000 we've currently got two applications
in that are being considered at the
moment
one to regional culture and heritage and
one to ttcf funding which
hopefully will bring us 516 000
which leaves us a shortfall of 137
000 but we have exhausted
all avenues of funding um
and we also are now running the risk
that uh some of that 553 000 will have
to be
returned to the funders the lottery's
grant of 300 000 has an expiry date of
november
and transpar also has an expiry date um
looming very shortly so we have
exhausted
all avenues for funding and we run the
risk
of of this project not going ahead and
the impact
on the community will be huge
the saint james theatre is a key
community asset
it fosters the arts and delivers a huge
amount of well-being and benefit for our
community
as a theatre consultant working right
throughout new zealand
and experience with many local
authorities in their theatres
gore or the james theatre gore is unique
it doesn't receive a subsidy for its
operation
council or otherwise and
in most provincial new zealand and main
cities
councils either own and operate those
theatres
and in the case of a couple that are
owned by trusts actually subsidise
their operation and that to a in in the
in two cases
is somewhere between 300 and 400
thousand dollars
per annum
since 1987 as i indicated before
gdc have supported this and james
theatre to the tune
of two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
for the trust to maintain this facility
for the community
it needs help so this submission today
we're seeking gore district council to
underwrite the funding required to this
facility
for this next step to ensure the funds
raised remain
available the amount of subject pending
as we've
mentioned could be between 137 000 to
653
000. your support will ensure that the
theater
is retained for all our community
and this aligns with the gore district
council's rural
city living ready for living
ready to grow and age friendly
it is the heart of our town
thank you okay look thank you very much
for that um
presentation and
it's now open for counsellors if they
need any clarity on what is being asked
for i think it's reasonably
straightforward although
i will ask if you could just perhaps
expand a little bit on what you mean by
asking the council to underwrite
an amount of money
um as mentioned um
it could be well basically at the moment
it's the
500 the 657
000 off the top of my head that was
such 653
is the short for at the moment yeah a
risk
is that um if
if if we don't get money to continue it
on
that funds that we have will start going
back so that amount will only increase
so i guess by the the question the
question i'm asking is what does
underwrite mean
um to pay to
meet the shortfall yeah okay yep
that's right just as long as we're clear
on what that means
okay um questions counselors
any clarification required look i think
it's a good submission
and i think everybody understands what
you're asking for
um and i just like to say thank you
for the submission if there's no other
questions oh there is
sorry uh question for the submitters
when will you know about your
applications
okay um the lah lottery environmental
heritage they
are due to make a decision tomorrow and
we meet to hear within the next 10 days
after that
um the ttcf funding um
it is um an application that we have
been told to put in
and so again because there are time
restraints with the money
we have held off putting it in but we
have been told
that uh that it would be probably well
supported
we need to have consent yes
yes we do before we can put in it needs
to have uh consent
um and the work would be the fun the
funds would be for
the refurnishment of the little theater
okay so that's where we've take a lot of
our funds have been
targeted for certain things like we've
put in applications like some of them
meet the criteria for structural work
so we can have to i isolate that out and
direct the application for that some of
it
is for lift so you know
that's how we've managed to break it
down but the total cost
of the project is 1.2 million
okay brett yeah thanks for submission uh
just a question around your project
budget
what certainty do you have on the 1.29
million i say you're calling for tenders
have you been through a qs process or
just yes we have a number um
design wise we're at um develop design
at this point
um the anticipation is that we will be
uh lodging for consent we've had pre-app
meetings with council
uh we'll be lodging for consent in
august and as soon as we lodge for
consent we'll be working through
um our pricing the procurement method
will be the same as we did with the
stage tower which
the trust we managed the risk for the
trust
and that paid significant dividends for
them in terms of the extent of the work
in terms of the dollars
the estimate has been done by registered
qs
and has been done in light of how we
would go about building the building so
the methodology has been worked through
with the construction manager that will
take the job forward that built
the stagehouse so we're reasonably
confident around the numbers what we
don't have control about is
uh the important product and cost
exchange rate which is why we have a
contingency sum
um consistently some sitting at about
114 000.
i passed around fifth to our submission
um just the use of the theatre
and on the back page we'll see that
we've got the touring productions the
community use
the 2 800 screenings per year plus
the gold musical there's annual
productions but
without the lord district council
support the saint james theatre
will inevitably close if the seismic
strengthening
is not done so um please
that would be a town without a heart
thank you yvonne i think i've heard you
say that before um
um brahman thank you your worship thank
you submitters it's a really good
application and submission um
i just wanted to know whether or not
does all the work that you need to do
have to be completed at once
so that you know maybe the little
theatre could be completed down the
track
uh do you want me to answer that
it's a part of it and then you can never
go um most of it does because
the where the structural work is done is
where the lift goes in
and the fact is that you can't put um we
would never be allowed to put
put the lift in because then you
couldn't do the structural work
uh and i don't think any of your
building inspectors would allow us to
um do that um but because we're opening
up that area the cost would go up
significantly
if we did them separately because we'd
be opening up the same areas
thank you okay um council macphail
yes thank you for your submission uh as
the other councillors alluded to it's um
well presented uh just the to confirm
the codependency between
the two associated businesses and the st
james theatre
so if the st james theatre than ever if
you have here inevitably closes
those two other associated businesses
will not function
um you're talking the okay
so the theater's owned by the trust
okay the business is leased out
to uh musical theater no in regard to
the other
two the other two businesses businesses
yes they they at least there so if the
building was shut
the um the movie business and the live
theater business would close the green
room would close in the sushi shop
because they are all within
that facility okay thank you
okay any further questions counselor
hosted
yeah thanks your worship um just a
question around financial information
obviously it's important
to this council that we support a viable
and ongoing
organization that's sustainable have you
provided a copy of the financials for
the
trust and the gmt um yes
the the trust every year i drop in
the financial statement once they're
audited and once they've been sent to
uh the charities commission so they have
been done every year
um the goal musical theater because we
it's like a business
lease separate to us um we don't
actually have
necessary access to that so that hasn't
been submitted
or can put to the given to the council
that would be
i guess a business decision for them
to that we would have to consult with
them about
okay i guess it's probably public
information on the on the company's
website
we could probably grab ourselves it's
just that's where the income is yeah
look at that you're a financials you're
as you're stated you're very much the
building owner yes the the actual income
generation
happens in that other organization i
appreciate what you're saying i'm sure
you can access that
yes okay any other questions
or comments from counselors if not
look thank you very much for your
submission and um we'll
get back to you we'll be deliberating on
all the submissions
uh in a week's time and we'll certainly
be in touch as soon as we possibly can
thank you thank you very much
okay public health south um and we have
dr
leanne liggett um welcome leanne you've
been here before i think a few times
okay
okay the um look the floor is yours uh
for ten minutes
and then there's likely to be questions
or yeah questions from councillors
thank you worship councillors and
staff the of the gore district council
as your worship has mentioned my name is
leanne liggett
i am an analyst at public health south
and i've also been
had the pleasure of facilitating all
long-term planning
um across the southern district which
actually entails
nine different plans so i've been
involved
with lots of reading and understanding
and so i must commend
the district council and putting
together a lovely plan
that is easy to read and with me here
today is gordon crombee
and he is a health promoter here at our
local invercargill office
and look in this post-covered world
public health is really looking to
maximize our effectiveness and how we're
supporting our communities
and already we work really closely with
your council staff
um we're making a really conscious
effort at the moment to provide upstream
uh input into policy development and
also
any other support that we can do so so
um
it won't surprise you to know that all
of the information that we put in
our submission the council staff
actually are familiar with this
nothing is new there and so because of
that
we're only going to mention and discuss
a couple of things with you guys today
so uh we are very as i as as i've
alluded to
uh we're really keen on working on
partnership
working together and understanding how
we can improve the health and well-being
in our district specifically here in
gore
and one of the things that we would like
to be able to provide
further supporters around the smoke-free
policies there has been a lot of good
work done in this area
in recent years we have smoke-free
ayatera 2025
almost upon us and there's just a few
more things that we'd like to be able to
provide
support to the council staff to you know
progress this
along secondly public health units
across the country
we're using the world health
organization's sustainable development
goals
and how we're doing our planning and how
we're actually communicating with
council staff and also councillors and
we really believe that this is a
fabulous
process that is worldwidely
acknowledged around council staff and
also how we can
look at things because it has a public
health approach because
of the 17 indicators that are captured
within this
it has time frames which fall through
to about a 15-year period so it allows
for things to happen
over time and it also is very easy for
us to reflect on how this
works from a council's perspective and
to demonstrate this tool gordon's going
to talk
about the streets alive project thank
you luanne
good afternoon you worship me higgs and
councillors
public health south acknowledges the
work that the school district council
has already begun with the streets alive
program
it's been a hard road today but we would
encourage you to continue with that
i'm alongside the pilot public health
south has been working with the four
primary schools in goa
to understand why they use active
transport and what can be done
to promote the use of active transport
within those
schools the feedback across all those
four schools has been pretty consistent
children want to be physically active
and they want to do it with their
friends
we asked children what would encourage
them to use active transport to get to
and from school as i said their
responses were pretty consistent
children want safe places to be dropped
off at and picked up from
away from the school gates thus reducing
congestion
around the school gates children don't
necessarily want to stop to play on the
way to and from school
but they do want their travel to be
interesting and they've
identified such things as murals on
walls
and the storybook trail children want
their journey to be safe
suggesting cycle trails across existing
green spaces they also want
places of interest to be easily
accessible
children identify traffic speed as a
deterrent to active transport
children want traffic slowing measures
put in place to make the school
journey safe some of the children we
spoke to
provided us with the following quotes
i walk a bite to school each day and i
like doing it as mum has a lot of skills
to go to so it's a lot faster i get
dropped off at sword street and walk
across the park
to come into school i walk two younger
children who have parents that teach at
gore high school
with my dad to and from where school
every morning and every afternoon
my cousin who is at st peters walks with
me to and from school when my
grandparents are working
i walk my two younger brothers to school
every morning
i walk to my mum's work at hello banana
after school
and get a lift home from there
active transport most commonly refers to
walking and cycling
but other modes include skateboarding
and scootering which a lot of children
currently do
research has repeatedly shown the health
benefits attached to active transport
but other benefits include the potential
for active travel to reduce car use
which would reduce congestion air and
noise pollution
as well as energy use and greenhouse gas
gas
emissions local authorities have a range
of policy options available
to them to encourage active transport
one of the main objectives
is to make active transport more
convenient and safer for users
as these factors have a large impact on
mobility choices
made by people the benefits
linked to improved walking and cycling
conditions and most of these were
identified by the school children
to reduce travel time and more comfort
for all pedestrians and cyclists
increased excel accessibility to
amenities
improved safety for vulnerable user
groups through increased visibility
reduced
traffic speeds and safer infrastructure
and reduced energy consumption
benefits linked to the reduced vehicle
usage
obviously reduced noise pollution
reduced greenhouse gas
and other harmful emissions increased
traffic safety through the reduction of
motorized traffic
reduced vehicle travel times through
diminishing congestion levels
improved quality of life through more
social interaction
improvement in private businesses by
increased
attractiveness of public spaces
and we actually spoke with staff at
the green room following or during the
trial period and they identified that
the improvements made as part of the
streets alive project
had made their business space more
attractive for people to stop
outside have the opportunity to continue
the changes that children have requested
you make
to allow their journey to and from
school to be safer and more enjoyable
you have the opportunity to plan
infrastructure that links people's homes
work and other places of interest
you have the opportunity to contribute
to the well-being
of the people of the gore district
through the promotion of active
transport
with all of its benefits
leanne referred to the sustainable
development goals earlier as a framework
to improve health outcomes for the
population
people's safety the inclusion of all
people
and climate change are three of those
development
goals
public health south would encourage you
to allow your town to thrive where
people can move around
easily and have a range of travel
choices for getting
to work in education connecting them
with family and friends
and the ability ability to access the
services in your town
thank you we welcome any questions you
may have
oh thank you gordon and leanne um just
one question i have
and you refer in your submission around
the well-being
um are recommending uh equity of access
to uh hamilton park be improved i guess
are you specifically
pointing towards the state highway one
crossing there or what does that mean
yes um when working with escort school
um
we attempted to to cross the road over
to hamilton park
um obviously it's a 70k zone there and
in
when you're coming down the hill it's
100k um
so access from directly from across the
school was very very difficult
and the children didn't feel safe doing
so it was actually three children with
myself and a teacher aid and
it didn't feel safe the park itself
there's some fantastic equipment in that
part but
most of the children at east school
school didn't access that park simply
because
of the safety issue of crossing that
the highway thank you uh
okay councillors questions
of leanne or gordon council garden
just um i noticed you mentioned
fluoridation for our water
is there any funding available from the
health department for that or do we have
to fund that as a council
just a question so
that is a process that is still with
central government at the moment
i thought it was important to include
that in all of our submissions around
long-term planning that
public health response around
fluoridation so we will always advocate
and support fluoridation in our
communities
and as things evolve over time
then i'm sure central government will
actually provide that support
for things to roll out but at the moment
it's in a hiatus
and we're hoping that
decisions will be made shortly but i
understand the decision has been moved
from councils
to health at this point that's where
the indication is where it's going
thank you any further questions from
councillors
there's not look thank you very much for
your interest
thank you for the submission and we'll
certainly deliberate on this
as time goes on thank you all
okay that brings us to the hokunu
mountain bike club
and richard richard are you and your
team ready to go
welcome along and so you have 10 minutes
for your submission
and there will be a ballot eight minutes
and a further one at ten minutes
thank you uh thanks for this opportunity
to speak to our submission
i would also like to thank the council
for their support to date
um through the ceo and the former parks
and reserves
manager um we have appreciated their
support over the last few years
and also uh thanks for the support by
the way the grant three years ago
to finish off the water race trail um
yeah so we
appreciate that we have a working
relationship with each other now
and over the past few years the club has
actually
um grown in strength to strength we have
a really strong
structure and committee now um
yeah we could just hold that for we took
things yeah
so yeah we'd just like to highlight a
few of the areas that we're working with
we have a strong club as i said a strong
committee and we've got quite a few
different
areas that we're working with and the
one on the video
now is at hamilton park so it is where
it's quite an interesting timing the
group before us was mentioning
access to hamilton park um so hamlet
park's got a great lot of facilities as
they mentioned there's you know the bmx
track there's plenty of places to walk
there's many places and so we've
developed a few wee mountain bike trails
in some tree areas in there um this is
by way of a funding grant from
local funders and a lot of volunteer
work so our club has got like i said a
strong
membership now so a lot of support so
we'd just like to play a little bit of
that clip but we could just just show
you
um a little bit about it
so
he thinks it should be enough
thanks uh yeah it gives you a bit of an
idea um so that's aimed at
it's not just a flat sort of trail
that's something a little bit more
advanced the kids families can have a
bit of fun on
we're also quite involved with the
trials over there that were a bit more
flatter and a bit easier gradient and
that
is you know you're probably aware how
the trees got fouled and they've
sort of been put on hold for a while so
we are quite keen and would like to stay
involved with the planning
of those uh what happens there in the
future the club's got a lot of
enthusiastic workers that would like to
see some of those trails reinstalled but
they when they can
uh now i'd like to move on to the cordon
bush i think we've got a photo there
i've just
didn't really get time to get some video
together we would have liked to
so a lot of you have heard about the
cord and bush track the waterways track
so that has been um
undergo for quite a while now we are
finally in the completion stages this
spring
yeah there we go uh so um our plans in
the future for that and once
um we do get the opening this spring is
to look at it
develop a few more trails through a
different variety of people
so at the moment we've got a sort of a
grade two three trail we'd like to look
at developing a few further trails
that will attract more people to the
area we're also
really keen to develop some history and
some storyboards around this trail
this is um it's quite a well-known
historical area
there was some a lot of tree felling
years ago gordon bush
we schooled et cetera out that way
obviously it was the mining
then there's a little legend of the
moonshine
story as well so you know we'd like to
think that if we could you know have
that all
on storyboards throughout the length the
trail that people would come to town
you know it's not just riding your bike
you're learning a bit of history you're
finding more about it
that's something that's probably outside
the club's skill set so
we would really like support with that
area just to help develop that side of
it
that we think would you know also be
great for local schools and kids as well
to learn a lot about their history
and move on to
the ready road trail so
oh yeah so this is something that some
volunteers begun work on it was
something that we
promoted and talked about for a number
of uh years and then finally one of the
local club members just decided just to
get in and start doing it to see what it
looked like
so this work is sort of halfway through
the
work you've done um it's it's a bit of a
better standard now
and we're in the process of funding
we're applying for funding to finish or
to complete this trial to a certain area
so what we want to do is link gore to
the cord and bush would then would link
gore to dolomo park
and so therefore you know kids and
families can safely ride from gore to
delaware park and also visitors
obviously you're all aware of e-bikes
now and in the past you might have
thought gee that could be a bit tough
but nowadays with e-bikes it makes it
such an easy
accessible trail and it's not just for
um you know it can be for any age group
you know it's skill level wise
you know the trail has got a few corners
on that shark but generally it's it's
pretty achievable i just rode the new
clyde cromwell one a few days ago and
it's certainly got plenty of sharp
corners on it too but it's it's very
busy
and very popular and so
um yeah that's just something that we're
trying to do a lot of its volunteer work
that the funding that we got last time
was to help get gravel the trap and we
are going to plan
do that the next few months to finish
that off so
there's not a lot of huge amount of
dollars involved because we do get a lot
of volunteer work in there and
the helicopter companies you know going
to do it for a cost price type of thing
so we are able to get a lot of support
from the community when we do these
projects and the same with what's been
done at riby road it's
you know being paid for a lot of
volunteers and local
businesses have donated things so we
will be trying to
get that link done out towards doleman
park later this year
and just following on what um the group
said before we believe hamilton park
access
is really um a priority that needs to be
looked at
there's a lot more cars on the road now
it's very very very busy and and with
the
developments coming up at hamilton park
it would be great to see
a safe way to get across there i know
i've tried it with my family a number of
times when they were a bit younger and
it's very challenging so yeah we'll just
put that there to be looked at as well
um so we're also asking the council to
consider an annual grant towards what
the club's doing for
cycling projects um you know obviously
we realize funding is not available so
we're asking for a
22-23 start
and we're asking for 25 000 per annum
and
we believe this is a huge area now
there's a huge
part of our community that cycles and
it's a very very small part
it's very small budget when you look at
other areas
and there's a lot of people doing it and
for that each dollar we
obviously can attract funding with that
dollar plus we've got huge amount of
volunteer support that come along and
help so
we believe it would be a really
worthwhile investment for our community
i mean as cycling's growing throughout
new zealand
and you know we are i guess behind a
little bit and
what's going on if you look around other
communities and
but we believe we've got a you know
beautiful native bush area to ride and
we've got something unique
a lot not many areas in new zealand have
such a beautiful native bush area
and to be able to link the town through
there we've got a chance to have
something
worthwhile you know for locals and for
visitors as well
thank you thank you richard
um okay councillors the doors open for
any questions
that you may want to ask this point in
time
counselor counselor grant
thank you worship richard you're uh
from from the previous uh
a few years ago with uh department of
conservation everything's all
everything's all hunky-dory with uh
department of conservation
hunky door is a nice word everything's
all yeah all
uh well and yes yes we uh
yes we've got um great support from
there now yeah we did have a hiccup if
you like
there for a little while um just just
had to get a few things clarified
and so we've been 12 months now back
meeting together and
and they're very very supportive
actually
and we're our club is also along outside
working
uh closely with the room nunger looking
at putting a trapping program in that
area um
you know that's something that some of
the club members are interested in as
well so
we are i know you know we want to use
the bush and some people think cycling
is a little bit
the outside bush use but if you see from
the photo or you
form a photo there it's a lot narrower
than it was the bush has grown back and
so we we do really want to protect that
push but we do want to see it being
accessed as well
turn your microphone on please
just hold it
i'll speak loudly it's a dad
thank you richard i'm just wondering if
you have numbers of
young people and right through to adults
that are using
the trails at present no we don't have
any formal
counters doc had one years ago but we
haven't actually talked about it i guess
that could be a good
way of showing how many people use it
with informal
um doc talk a lot of uh i don't know if
anyone's heard of strava but it's all
it's a lot of riders put their rides on
this community page
like facebook except it's just that we
met and they had a lot of heat maps oh
and they showed us
the amount of people riding and um it
was
huge numbers and you know they they
realize a lot of people
are using it but we haven't actually put
any formal counters in
i guess there's a lot of things the club
can do there's a lot we sort of
haven't got ability to do we haven't
tried to do yet
okay thank you councilman
you know thanks richard for the
presentation there um
just in regard to the sort of that
closing um um
paragraph and the submission there um
that government's obviously investing
you know in the central otago um if we
got like you guys are obviously
established in there or you've got some
contacts so that they're seeing what
you're doing and
as we're increasing stuff like with
central government
um around sort of
if we're going to be assisting
that if it grows to you know the next
level
they are in in the know
not as far as i'm aware that the
government was
only committing to key towards the areas
the john key type funding from years ago
so that's
we're not actually a key towards the
area unfortunately well we've got access
to the
local community trust the mlt the
lottery's grant
which is what we'll be applying to for
this roadside and further development
there
it's yeah it's not it's huge money
obviously
like what they put into those other
trials but if there's something and you
know something's better than nothing i
guess
i don't know how to get access to those
other funds okay
all right thanks councillor
yeah thanks for hosted submission uh
richard and drew um look i think it's
real credit to
the club in terms of what's it what it's
achieved but could you just tell us a
little about your club structure in
terms of
how you're how you're organized to
deliver
these projects you seem to have quite a
quite a bit on the go
um just yeah so the council can
understand
how the club actually works yes yeah so
we we realized a few years ago that we
probably were a little bit unstructured
with informal if you like and had a few
challenges from it so we've got to
commit it if you like um
i guess you might call them a board now
rather than a committee or we want them
committed to be there for
you know a 12-month period in the next
12-month period so then rather than just
have a club
some clubs do you turn up casually
whatever so we're quite committed now
and we've got um leaders for each key
area so andrew here
leads the the review road development
project um jared hopefully somebody
knows leading that
cordon bush area and um ewan
it leads to hamilton park area so i kind
of don't
get involved with hands-on sort of some
of that stuff but just trying to be just
trying to oversee and
coordinate so we have small subgroup
meetings that meet in between our
monthly meetings and you know especially
this one's side of the road project's
been quite a big project
um to to fundraise to or to get the um
i guess the project established what's
going to cost and what you have to do
so yeah so we meet um in between if we
need to
and we have like i said we've got a
dozen people committed to turning up
each month
to help support the group the tnc or our
club rooms now they've got a board room
which is
quite thankful for that great
okay counselors any further questions
there's not look thank you um richard
and andrew for your submission
and uh we as i've said before we'll be
considering these in
depth and having some deliberations next
week
so we'll um we'll certainly be back in
touch with you as soon as we can
so thank you thank you
okay sport southland we've got jess and
gemma would you like to come forward
please
welcome along
so the floor is yours
eastern regional active coordinator for
sport southampton
gorges
general manager sport southland firstly
we have an apology from our chief
executive brenda mcdermott
he is on school camp and he sends his
apologies for not being here
we'd also like to start by saying thank
you thank you and congratulations for
the work
you and your team do in the gore
district we are sure the tough decisions
that are made and the work being done
is often taken for granted so we wanted
to thank you for the investment that you
make to allow this community
to be active through play active
recreation and sport
in addition we would like to acknowledge
the work that ian soper did in his parks
and recreation role
for 16 years also thank you to your
chief executive steve
your worship mr hicks and your various
teams for your future focused and
positive attitude working with south
sport southland we have an excellent
relationship
over many years and we're sure and look
forward to many more to come
as two different organizations we
believe we have the same kopapa
we both want happy healthy connected
people and communities where everyone
can thrive sport southland is not just
about sport
we're here to enhance individual and
community well-being through being
active
in whatever way that looks a lot of
councils big financial decisions often
involve replacing aging infrastructure
and continuing to deliver essential
services however we should not forget
about investing in people and their
well-being
by activating spaces and places ensuring
they are vibrant
relevant fit for purpose and accessible
we can enable happy
healthy and connected communities who
will continue to use these assets for
years to come
in our written submission we supported
supported the following options
continued activation of key spaces in
places such as gore's tracks and trail
networks
dolomial park and the gore multi-sport
complex
we also see play as a critical component
to ensure that a generation does not
miss out on the wonderful experiences
that play has given many of us
we suggest putting a play lens on all
assets such as the old goal library the
heritage precinct upgrade and maruwai
centre development
and the new gore library and james
[ __ ] community centre
we strongly encourage council to
consider creating a play strategy
that also incorporates a playground
review we know the other south and
councils are looking at this and we see
it as an excellent collaboration project
talking collaboration over the past 18
months we have been working alongside
your team
the other councils and funders with the
development of the southland regional
spaces and places strategy
this is now ready for adoption or
endorsement by all organizations
involved
one of the key successes to this project
to date has been the positive
conversations and sharing that has
happened collectively and
collaboratively between the councils
funders and ourselves we now have a
strategy
a good stock taker facilities and good
momentum from working together
let's not lose this momentum it is key
that we continue this mahi
and we propose that all partners invest
collaboratively in a small resource to
keep the strategy and the actions moving
forward
this resource would work alongside
councils funders and applicants and
ensure that we have a better information
to support decision making
and help better utilize and maximise the
potential of assets that we have
or look to build in the future the sport
southland board have adopted the
strategy and will allocate 40
of the resource cost and are looking to
councils and funders to partner with us
over the next three
years to ensure the regional spaces and
places strategy
is implemented well and does not become
another strategy on the show
we already have commitment from icc and
as another key partner
a partner who would be a major
beneficiary of this work we are looking
to gdc to invest five percent
which is 10k per annum gdc have a number
of sport
and recreation facilities on its land a
large number of these facilities are
single use
and or seasonal facilities that vary in
quality with most rating only average to
good condition
if we can better help utilize and
maximize the potential of these assets
by working with groups earlier
we can help prevent these facilities
becoming a liability for council
it is critical we take a more strategic
aligned and collective approach to
future investment into our sport and
recreation facilities
by being a partner you also have the
potential opportunity to leverage other
funding from the likes of sport
zed as a key partner your support and
leadership are critical
without it the opportunity to fully
realise the objectives of the strategy
diminishes
in closing we want to reiterate our
thanks thank you for your time
investment and commitment to the people
of the gore district sport south and
look forward to continuing our
partnership and together supporting a
community
which not only grows but thrives na
mahinui
thank you thank you for the submission
um
just a question from myself um with
regard to
regional spaces and places so you're
looking for a commitment
of ten thousand dollars it was from us
um can you put that into context and
just talk a little bit about
what that is looking like across the
region and
who's involved and what we're going to
get for that
um so the resource as mentioned is a
role
um it would be an employee based at
sport southland and it would sort of be
a first port of call for any group that
came through
it would all run work as a conduit to
pass between councils funders and all
the other stakeholders
that were involved across the strategy
today so everyone held a place on a
steering committee
right from the iteration of this project
to now so
it would just be a continuation of
supporting all of those groups they
would retain their own
individual decision making but it would
be a a way to bring them together i
suppose
thank you okay open for question
counsellors
everybody's struck dumb
counselor grant thank you your worship
thank you for your submission
um can you just can you elaborate a
little bit on your play
strategy at all
just a little bit we know um
through the work we've been working
alongside the streets of life project
as well and we know that um for gore
district it
it's baby steps it very would be very um
earliest times for what play means in
our region
um but by way of example with uh
where sport and z changes come from they
used to refer to everything as
sport and recreation sport and
recreation now their wording is always
play
active recreation and sport so the
highlighting that importance of that
play for our youth
but also intergenerationally is hugely
important and what that may look like
across the board for a council could be
very different um
but we would hope that it's something
that sort of becomes
the norm and any projects that are being
done that that play lens is added over
the top so it becomes
uh part of anything that's happening so
that families or anybody in the region
has a the time place and permission to
to play
all right thank you
nothing further councillors look thank
you very much you've got away lightly
thanks for the submission and like
others i've said
we'll be considering this over the next
week and certainly be in touch once
we've made some decisions
thank you thank you everyone
oh right
okay um we have caught up a little bit
of time we've got
uh a couple of presentations
who aren't going to be coming and
talking to us today uh chord in aviation
and ian's davidson what
um which brings us to murugaku kai
collective
uh stella o'connor is stella here
welcome stella come along
and we're keen to hear
muruhikukai is something new to me i
hadn't
heard about it until i read the
submission so i'm keen to learn a little
bit more about
what it does and why it's doing it
thank you uh killer koto your worship
counsellors
good district council staff uh course
stella o'connor
no matter how so my name is stella
o'connor
and i'm here today speaking on behalf of
the mirahiku kai collective
and thank you for this opportunity it's
amazing
so the mirahiku kai collective is made
up of a number of community groups
who formed around the common vision of
enabling southlanders
to have the capability to produce and
access
good food so we are newly formed
like last year and we also have some
invercargill city council staff from
parks and rec
team and from wastenet along
and that have contributed to our
collective and we have submitted
to the other long-term plans for
invocable city council
south and district council and
environment southland
so the southland territorial authorities
have repeatedly shown a commitment to
building strong cohesive vibrant
communities
and we know that you all value the
importance of community wellbeing
so while there are parts of our
community that are thriving
there are also pockets where the
opposite is a reality
and feedback from these communities and
families show that one of the major
struggles is access to quality
nutritious food
and this has been exacerbated by the
onset of covert 19 pandemic as well
so i just want to ask you to remember
back to last year with the onset of
covert 19
there would have been a point in time
where everyone in this room
would have experienced that panicked
feeling
that they might not have access to food
to feed their families
that that feeling may have been fleeting
for you
but for some of the families we talk to
this is a reality most days
so the pandemic exposed inequalities but
it also revealed solutions
bottom up and top down and we know that
there are more shots and crises are
coming
in fact we've got a flood at the moment
and a bridge broken
so there's a supply chain that's broken
for us
so we have the chance to build a more
secure sustainable resilient local food
system
one that is healthier and supports
people more fairly
and we're here to see the curio about
how together we can all support
a regenerative local food system that is
prepared in times of natural disasters
climate change supports
self-sustainability
promotes and supports local food
production
and the need to provide adequately for
our communities
so we've asked all the other southland
councils to come on board
and help us lead the progress in this
space
and help co-design and adopt a mirahaku
food resilient strategic plan
and this could be used by departments
across territorial authorities and
councils to inform
and support their current and identify
future work programs and activities
relating to food security
and food sovereignty so there's various
actions that we have
tabled and the submission that councils
can support and promote
alongside community action as well to
reduce the barriers
so that our local food producers are
supported
more of our community are growing their
own produce and our most vulnerable
have access to good food imagine
by 2013 southland has a booming local
food system that provides good food to
businesses
organizations communities and
individuals and in order for southland
to have a booming
local food system by 2030 we need to
make a plan
so now is the time to commit and include
food resilience while looking at the
long-term planning
so that our regions will have thriving
social economic and physical
environments
providing healthy affordable and locally
grown food for all people
so i'm not here asking for money which
is a great thing but just commitment to
attend
workshops and to think about the role
that you can play
as a council thank you thank you
stella for the presentation thank you
for the work that you're doing
um one thing that this community is is
well known for is its connectedness
and i'm just wondering if you're
connected with any other organizations
like the committee networking trust for
example
who are actively working in not
particularly this
base but it will be a space that this
would fit with very well
do you have any connection there at all
um
not with a not with that organization
that you just spoke about
um so we are newly formed from late last
year and we've mainly
um i think i've said in the submission
the organizations that we've got on
board but
um this is just the beginning and we
really want to seed it and we want to
bring um
all communities along and connect the
dots for people
and as um great presentation i've just
followed from you saw
the sport sports outfit would like a
play lens across the work that you do
we're talking about a food lens across
the work that you do
so it might be your procurement policies
where possible and practical you procure
from local providers
just things like that but okay thank you
okay councillors um open for any
question councillor
thank you your worship thank you stella
that was a good submission
i do have a query about um i see one of
your short-term goals
is the allotment gardens now is that for
groups or for individual people to take
advantage of
uh so that was a short-term goal for the
maruhaku kai collective
so whereas is
they are suggested goals that we're
going to be doing ourselves
the mirahika kai collective
and so we're looking that's through
kohakai
who are looking at allotment gardens and
trying to
um help with those is that what you're
referring to yeah so what was your
question sorry um
yeah individuals and groups
any other questions counselors
a councillor garland are you weird
i'm not sure if um material had a
gardens
yeah amazing and also i think calvin
church at um
they were running a community garden yes
yeah okay look if there's no further
questions
thank you for your submission thank you
for making us aware of
of what you do and how you go about it
and um
we'll come back to you when we make our
deliberations about what we do for us
next thank you very much
okay um we'll move on then to
rural ratepayers group and we have um
peter and mark
welcome along gentlemen come and have a
seat
and forward to hearing your thoughts
yes thank you for the opportunity
to present this uh if if you could just
use the microphone then
people that are watching this on a live
stream will be able to hear what you're
saying that's cool yeah
okay thank you mr tracy and councillors
thank you for
the chance to come along today and
address you um
submission to the 10-year plan 2021-2031
the proposed water pipeline and walk
bridge to e-score
this whole proposal has antagonized
rate-paying residents who have to live
near it
and look at it we would support the
sensible option of laying the pipeline
beneath the riverbed
directly to escort as was done for the
materia valley milk water supply
this has been fully discussed locally
and savings are likely to be in the
order of two to three million dollars
the swing bridge will be high
maintenance the wire rope structure
likely to vibrate
and create noise and different wind
speeds
the present road bridge has a walkway
for pedestrians on both sides
road traffic efficiently monitors and
moderates pedestrian behavior
on the lonely walk bridge hundreds of
meters upstream he was going to monitor
violent activities drug dealing fighting
in the areas of darkness
security cameras well good luck with
those wearing hoodies
the unwillingness to save many millions
of dollars
contrasts sharply with the council
quoted savings of twenty thousand
dollars
with the installation of synthetic
carpets versus wool carpets within the
new council headquarters
council should have a policy that
wherever possible local product
be showcased the crossbred wall as a
carbon sink is renewable
it's biodegradable and doesn't require
cancer causing fire retardant to be
incorporated during manufacture
it has grown locally and as part of our
local economy
from growers to sharers and their
families i just had a quick look at some
local menus last night on the internet
and you notice this otometer
valley lamb racks on water at
restaurants and gore
the silver fern uh special reserve aged
beef
available they showcase local product
and i think that's a good thing to do i
think should have a policy on that
it's quite shameful basically that you
overlooked wool
um so synthetic products carpet ends up
clogging landfills it doesn't break down
how does this council decision compare
with council
statement on page 18 on rubbish and
recycling
council has little restraint on
expanding funds on frivolous activities
you cannot support a district primary
product
we've attached literature there on fire
retardant and other chemicals applied to
synthetic carpets
and the risks involved a statement from
calif cavalier corporation
sustainability is important to us after
the rush towards synthetic carpets in
the last 10 to 15
years people are now realising the
benefits that wool offers
and we are seeing consumers turning back
to beautiful woolen carpets for colour
innovative style performance and its
natural benefits
walt was 100 natural it's grown in new
zealand it keeps you warmer in the
winter
cooler in the summer it's naturally
stained soil and fire resistant
all really does take all the boxes and i
was just thinking about this
if you remember after the first attack
on the twin towers they had smoke
and all sorts of damage took place there
it wasn't the time it was destroyed
but they commented at the time how will
stood up to the traffic
and that particular incident was able to
be cleaned up and put back
in and was quite a selling point for
wool there's also the people in
england in that fire rise building
they blame the synthetics too a lot of
people lost their lives
and it is a danger for firemen who get
to go to the incidents like that
with synthetics um the rural special
fund we support option one
apply all the rural special fund to the
pyramid bridge debt reduction i think
our last submission we had here
we suggested that so we've got to
continue to support that the pyramid
bridge is
uh the rural special fund is a rural
legacy and needs to be invested in a key
rural asset
the sooner the better there's inflation
and whatever
continues to degrade the buying pair and
the value of that fund so an interest
rate return
is inconsequential the bridge is seen as
a very important asset
and will be a benefit to all rural
ratepayers
um the old goal library not the really
old one the one in the middle
clearly option three as we've all heard
over the years about the unfixable
uneconomic ruined state of that building
repairs have never been seen to be an
option
burdening anyone was talk of a trust or
whatever been given it
burdening anyone or any other
organization with this liability
would not be a kind action and given
council's weakness for a hard luck story
ratepayers would again be facing
expensive repairs
to the old library we say demolish
plant lawn end of story any alternative
to this action would
could should be seen as part of a
disingenuous agenda
by the council interest rate risk to
ratepayers
council debt continues to grow
conforming to a set formula
widespread opinion is mixed apparently
according to some low interest rates are
here for a long time
this may or may not be true there are
manifest indicators abounding of
international instability
in the interests of transparency and the
fully informed ratepayer base
council should include and future plans
a table
or a graph demonstrating the effect on
rate demands
short interest rates increase unpaid
property rates result
in property seizure and sale people
ratepayers
landowners have a right to understand
the risks
of increased right interest rates and
just what council
has signed them up for
the question on page 20 why change
we say it is not sensible to dissolve
the three separate
entities to create a single rating area
because
rural is a completely different animal
to the urban areas
this whole idea rex of desperation
because the gore district has become
unsustainable
due to a small population a lack of
economy of scale
of sound financial and sound financial
management
such a move to a single rating area
would precipitate an immediate move by
rural ratepayers to push
for amalgamation with neighbouring
districts
the suggestion of a single rating area
is the follow-on of an apparent council
agenda
to bundle distinct disparate communities
of interest together
rural people have faced the imposition
of single ward election at large by this
council several times in the past
this was roundly rejected by rural
people and the
local government commission agreed the
local government commission understands
the difference between right
and wrong we've attached a
copy of minutes and statements of from
mayor ferry
to a meeting of east and south and
sub-executive federated farmers before
the gore district was formed
and it gives you an idea what rural
people thought they were signing up for
local government rationalization the
government has currently moved to clean
up the health system by streamlining
services
and removing dead wood and ballast
approximately 20 plus ceos etc
and the health sector are facing the
guillotine to deliver cost savings for
better health
outcomes for the public for years
submissions
have illustrated the fact and the
problem of residents of neighbouring
districts flowing in to use school
district amenities
at the expense of gore district
ratepayers it has become more attractive
to live outside the district
and cross the boundary and used to go
amenities
the present administrations has had
years to address this issue
and has avoided exploring options
for example in the feedback form council
could or should have sounded out the
views of citizens to seek whether they
prefer the status quo
or would consider participation in a
larger district
just yeah years ago the google district
was formed by the amalgamation of gore
and the matera boros with a small rural
hinterland
why was this done the answer
unsustainability and duplication
30 years later we have reached the
tipping point of duplication
and unsustainability central government
has in recent days signaled a major
shake-up in local government
and with the present government actions
speak louder than words
it is interesting to note that in 1989
when the district was formed
gore had a population of fourteen
thousand five hundred people
thirty years later we have reached
twelve thousand five hundred
what has gone wrong and i was thinking
this morning we can't
do this without mentioning streets alive
one doesn't like to be unkind but this
hasn't resonated positively with locals
the old warning about greeks bearing
gifts applies here
it would have been better to save the
council contribution of the 100
dollars and keep that for free for
yourselves
there's been several good points in the
whole thing but
i sort of feel the two worst
intersections haven't been touched state
highway one
and the charlton road intersection there
that's a bad one likewise the huron
street railway estimate remains
untouched
they should have been dealt with they
would have done done a good job
gina campbell daughter of donald the
speed record enthusiast was here in the
south 30 years ago and she was effusive
in her praise of the wide open streets
that we enjoyed in the south here
and i think we should preserve that
streets are like arteries and it's crazy
to block them
there's been mentioned locally about
maize i know when you go to gore
sometimes you think hell i've got to get
home how do i get home
i've got to think about it and this
matrix i've built up in the lifetime
i've got a zigzag my way across school
to get home
to me the scheme is a bit like buying
100 litres of drench
just to get a fluffy toy so we've
reached 10 minutes
um is that the end of your submission
okay
thank you okay so open for questions
just a quick one
query from me you mentioned an
attachment from
former mayor ferry uh yes we've got a
um can you deliver that there's an
attachment yeah you gotta
give you a copy there like um here's an
attachment there what
has reported comments back then right
thank you
um okay open for questions
counselors any questions you have of the
rural ratepayers group
counselor guarding yeah peter mark if
um if say if the streets alive we could
deliver
uh less tarsal would that not lower our
ratepayer
cost is that a good thing or a bad thing
if we narrowed the streets and gore and
um had less tar sale to maintain
the rates would go down would you agree
with that
what would you do with the street
there's one suggestion we could put some
tiny houses on it
okay okay okay what's the current
maintenance slot of natasha and gore
anyway
look not a question we can answer at the
moment what
what any other questions counselors have
got
no there's not look thank you for your
submission
and we'll consider the points that
you've
made and this time next week we'll be
making some
decisions around which way we go with
the various suggestions that have been
made by
a variety of group so thank you thanks
uh south and federated farmers now i
don't know that federated farmers are
coming are they do they intend coming
no no no they don't so they have
provided a written statement for
councillors to consider
and we will consider that
[Music]
along with the other submissions that we
have is there anything
in that written statement that councils
want to ask a question about at this
point in time if we need to find out any
more
information it does not
we'll move on then to um
sally mcintyre sally i think you're
just a wee bit before time but if you're
willing to come forward
you know invite you to come along
thank you
mine'll be very short because i thought
i only had five minutes
have you i'm sure you will stretch it
out
um okay so look the the floor is your
sally we've got um
you've got 10 minutes and uh councillors
will be
able to um ask any questions or
clarification that they
they may need at the end of that time so
if you could use the
the microphones on right there or it's
on yes
i don't have to put it down no that's
fine thank you
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to you today
as i only have a few minutes i'm going
to only lightly touch on some issues
and go into further detail that i want
to focus on
my key points largely focus on potential
cost savings
prudent decision making and transparency
many of you will know that i am
passionate about local democracy
and i have been characterized by some
around council
somewhat unfairly in my view is a bit of
a tinfoil hatter
therefore i would invite councillors to
hear what i have to say with an open
mind
i'll skip through the first couple of
issues firstly stormwater separation
i believe it is appropriate for the
proper owner to fund the work
that's option one and secondly on the
special rural fund
i'd like to see the funds retained for
future use
that benefits the rural community that's
option four
i believe there would be great benefit
in engaging with rural ratepayers
about the use of this fund over the next
few years
there appears to be no need for
councillors to rush into a decision now
while retirement of debt is always an
attractive option
the pyramid bridge debt has also been
careful
carefully planned by council to be paid
off without applying these funds
i now invite you to consider how best
you might
might allocate your limited rate payer
funding on discretionary spending
and this is where i believe it is useful
to think about the future of the old
gore library
and the mourawaya development additional
funding is one
discretionary funding poll
consider together the additional funding
for stage 2
of 360 000 along with the council's
preferred
option of retaining the old library
building
as part of this precinct which might
cost council around
400 000 or so means that council is on
the cusp
of allocating three-quarters of a
million dollars to projects
that require real scrutiny in this
covert environment
tourism and visitor numbers are down
significantly now
and for the foreseeable future you only
have to look at how queenstown is
struggling
and they have top tier attractions
the mourawaya centre i'm not sure i'm
pronouncing that correctly
my um
has was thought about when destination
places
were the hot new trend and there were
plenty of tourist-filled
buses on the road and international
travel
was free flowing stage one was scheduled
to be completed by march this year
and although it is running late the
museum reopening will be a good test to
see if the council's investment so far
will be successful in attracting more
visitors to gore
i must mention that i really appreciate
the information provided to me about
this project by the mayor
given that no staff time is invested in
stage one
i'm curious about when the council
stopped providing secretarial support to
the trust
and whether the project has any
oversight at all
given that the arts curator must not be
providing regular
reports to the trust committee
i only hope that the young accountant on
the trust is keeping tabs on
everything otherwise it might all end
really badly with cost blowouts i've
asked the pgf
people to let me know if they are
getting reports or monitoring this
project
if the council was to use this 750
000 of discretionary funding on core
activities this would go a long way to
improving
maintenance of rural roads around the
district
or getting the sewage ponds cleaned
councillors you might like to think
about getting the chief executive
to advise how these options would
benefit the community instead
especially as this would be more
consistent with council's objectives
stated in its financial policies
also i am sure you are all keen to avert
any repeats of experiments like the
matai ridge investment
which was an embarrassment for council
and sits like a big
expensive white elephant on the
council's books
the unprofessional approach taken to
that so-called property development
was a big disappointment to council
turning to other matters i have noted in
my submission
that there could be significant savings
if the council looked at taking a
different approach to the cable stay
bridge
it is questionable that the council
should pursue its current
path and be locked into an rma appeal
which could go on for years
and may put the nzta funding offered at
risk
and finally i am looking forward to
engaging to the council engaging
robustly on the rating system changes
and broader local government reform i
also look forward
to improve transparency
if i was a chief executive i would be
asking
how can i provide the clearest and most
transparent breakdown
for rate payers in terms of what each
rate payer was paying
i then would be putting a lot of effort
into ensuring
my staff produced rating notices notices
that were informative for the average
rate payer so that rate payers
had an itemized breakdown of what they
were paying
for each activity that this has recently
ceased is upsetting
but i look forward to this being given
prompt attention and priority
as it is one of the key tools to provide
ratepayers
with confidence that their rating
dollars are being appropriately spent by
the council
and that staff are being held
accountable for the effective delivery
of these services
this also gives the community confidence
that the chief exec executive is up to
the job
and delivering for the council thank you
for the opportunity to submit
i'm happy to take questions from
counselors
thank you thank you councillors and
thank you sally for the time you've put
into
the submission and like i've said to
others we'll be considering this over
the next week and make some
deliberations about this time next week
thank you thank you for the opportunity
right big pattern
oh have we not got a copy either either
okay yeah yeah thank you
okay um your timing is
impeccable ernie um welcome along
and we're we're just running a little
ahead of time so
uh if you'd like to come forward and um
you were there's an opportunity for you
now to um to speak to councillors
so just if you just come up to the table
up here
so the the microphones on there ernie
and hopefully
um they'll be able to pick you up
because we are
um live streaming this particular
meeting so
people will be watching from afar so
i'll give you a couple of minutes to get
yourself ready and then we're keen to
hear what
um what you have to say
oh good afternoon councillors um
i've been in this chamber before many
years ago
but anyway i'll just go over
one or two of the items about and when
it
worked out
the question one i support that
operation that uh that option one
uh the property owner to fund the work
in my case i paid for full storm water
drain right under the river terrace and
the river considerable expense
i think it's only fair that that private
ownership property owner should pay for
up to the streetcar i could well have
done the cheap way by putting the
downpipe down with it
with the siphon system to the street
cutter but at the side together
the four weights as i could and drain
any parts around the
home section now question two the plans
for the
old library building a support option
two
but redeveloped as an event center
it's important they're all sensitive
sections of the gore district council
community and not just the arts are
considered
the arts are more than catered for with
the options for the displays with space
at the gallery the heritage center the
distillery the rock street church
with its artist and residence flat and
the large
church hall over there which become
their home
and also rooms at the um
at the jameson coming week an event
center will be available to all the
community and not just a few for all
sorts of
functions such as a conference room
federated farmers and women's division
meeting places
for art displays trade displays
modern and ballroom dances youth dances
family reunions funerals weddings and
catering
during festival week and rooms for any
other type of operation
the children's area may release to a
caterer
for a cafe for an all-round all year
round cafe
separated from the main area with
folding doors
opened up as needed the roof 75
of the existing roof is in good
condition including the frontal
appearance of the building
and does not need replacing having over
50 years experience in installations of
every type of
roofing including my apprenticeship when
only plumbers were trusted with roofing
installations
and and flashings i know that the
roof-mounted air-conditioned
unit with its poorly flashed
penetrations
is the main cause of the leaks plus the
flat roof design
being a natural gathering area for
leaves
with the parabot uh there
it is a natural place for for
wind blown leaves to to accumulate
when blown dust and leaves accumulated
between the metals
to metal flashings and with no air space
result results in
capillary attraction allowing the rain
water over time to saturate the roof
timbers
were leaks opening at quite some
distance from the real cause
the effects of compelling retraction and
how to avoid it is taught to all
plumbing apprenticeships
if you want to know about compiler
attraction i'll give you two instances
uh if you put two sheets of glass with a
blotting vapor between them and that
tray of water
eventually the water will run right up
and over the top of them and exactly the
same thing effect happens
if you put a bath full of water and you
leave your towel on the bath
that towel will eventually drain the
whole bath onto the bathroom floor
a newly designed pitch roof over the
southeast area is essential
to overcome the leaking problems and
encase the air conditioning unit
with only the south eastern flat roof
uh having to be placed the one one
million dollars set aside
could very well cover most if not all
of the renovation costs
now to get on to the future of the royal
fund
i support option four join the first
gorgeous
council i was chairman of the royal
affairs committee
the fund of 980 000 came from the core
district council share of the forestry
section
of the old southland county council per
land transfer to the gore district a
proposal from the last late harvard
young
was an option for the gore district
council to purchase 150 hexes
of reasonably good hilltop land
for 350 000
and to use the then task force green
to plant the trees was put to the mayor
who flatly rejected the proposal and
refused to put on the agenda
that land now is a forestry as a forest
reaching maturity and the trees valued
well in excess of six figures
with land still available for future
planning
so you would have had quite a few
million dollars and
in there rather than that small poultry
farm you got left
the new incoming councillors then
decided on a feel-good
policy of funding any worthwhile
district program
such as giving 80 000 to the waikaka
bowling globe
to everybody knows has now gone belly up
and that was wasting money
to preserve the balance i suggest one
way to assist farmers is to supply
riparian plants for fenced areas on the
district waterways at cost
the reserve department has proved their
ability with plant work
plant stock and it was excellent land
beside the sewage ponds
was made available will be a worthwhile
cause
that land incidentally was originally
grasslands division where they developed
trees for the reserves in gore
and i beg of you please don't give the
fund away
to help the minority of world whiteface
um if you have any questions you want to
ask me i've got
further comments on since running
doing that um i've thought
seriously about the whole 10-year
program and there are
other uh ideas which i have have
so do you want me to you still have time
ernie if you'd like to um
okay well i'll present this now well i'm
surprised that only three subjects were
asked about
and that and that done that particular
and this particular
brochure put out so what about say
on one a review of council heads staff
from the top down
if central government ministers can
handle more than one portfolio
surely councilman and managers with
their
supplied vehicles can do the same such
as the finance minister being the fine
being the finance assistant to the
district manager et cetera
two a review of councillors do we really
need 12 members
the mayor's date of the councillors
decide the agendas
if so then it should be part of the
10-year plan
to become more open to the public i've
had lots of comments about our ghost
councillors
who seemingly are not pulling their
weight are never heard
and want most items to be held in
committee
the rate post want to know who you are
and for you to justify your position
with robust
debate act at open council meetings
if you're not prepared for that then ask
yourself
should i really be here
and the other last one is the
the santa claus handouts by the
government
up to now the council has been happy to
receive them
but each one has come at great increase
in cost to the ratepayers
in years to come the library
has moved from pulley to post with more
increases in costs
the pretty streets what are some model
letters
after it is over perhaps the filled
boxes
could be donated to pensioners for
raised vegetable gardens so as they can
find it
quite hard to bend down at times
the bridge of the cycleway not yet
costed and the continued run on fade
drain on funding for every reason to do
something
there are alternatives and that's what
the council is there for
to find a better alternative and not to
go along with the status quo
thank you thank you ernie um
so open for any questions that
counselors may have
at this point i think you've been fairly
clear
and and your thoughts on on a number of
issues and and i thank you for that
um i don't think counselors have i would
just
make a comment and an eye along with
yourself were part of that
first school district council and and i
well remember the debate around
the hilltop land of 150 acres and going
and visiting and looking
at what the opportunities were and
and probably we didn't make the right
call at that stage
but there certainly was a full council
debate uh
on that particular project
the waikaki bowling club that's one of
the reasons
that the rural fund was locked up
so that it couldn't be used for projects
such as that
into the future uh and now it's been
allowed to
to build to a reasonable size so that's
particularly good so just acknowledge
those two points that you
you did made mate okay councillors
um nothing else look thank you ernie for
taking the time
and thank you for arriving early and
being prepared to speak early and as
clearly as you did so thank you
all right right we're still um ahead of
time
yeah yeah um
so i'm just looking around the room to
see who's
who's here that is a submitter and you
know those hamish
guy you've just come in you're not down
to speak until four o'clock but
there is an opportunity if you'd like to
now just to come and share your thoughts
with councillors so
feel free
sometimes supposed to be early it does
depends what you got to say
well um just keep getting myself
organized um thank you for um
for um having me here today and i
acknowledge
wish the mayor and felik and the
councillors and i more so acknowledge
the process
um the process to me is a two-way thing
it's a time for council and executive
staff to consult with ratepayers
but it is also a time for ratepayers to
express their views
and concerns and one of the the most
important things
i picked up on in the 10-year document
is water
whether it's waste water storm water
or good old hto at the tap
what a major issue and central
government are compounding this issue
with
changing the evolving regulations and
the new water regulator
coming into force um the funding of
i don't know whether i should put my
nose in this or not but the funding of
um
separation of wastewater and stormwater
and pipelines and um in gore
needs to be done on a coordinated
approach
the council pipe work on the street
can't
could be recovered by option three with
the with a um
but the property work be funded by
individual ratepayers or the property
owners
the non-compliant property owners that
don't want to um
like was struggling for a good bit of
term to put their
property uh non-compliant property
owners that
aren't prepared to fund their own
property work
the council could loan them the money
and be collected back at a targeted rate
over a period of years
this would have to be carefully
implemented on a street by street basis
and of course communication and
diplomacy
would have to be at the utmost between
council property owners
and private contractors
the other thing i wish to touch on while
we're talking about water as um
this new regulator i call it ta
being a scottish heritage my maori
pronunciation isn't that
fluent i sometimes call it taken
and abuse maybe at the moment it'd be
be prudent for council to delay any
spending until the regulator's
fine print is known to you all
but i do want to say this the water
pipes and associated infrastructure is
owned by all
current ratepayers and more importantly
the water is
owed by no one or owned by
no one sure the council has a consent
for its water take
but that does not give anyone ownership
of water
only the right to use the volume of
water consented
if the new crown the entity thinks
different we should all turn the lights
out
and move somewhere else
now the main thing i want to talk about
in my verbal submission
is the idea of having a
lesser complex rating system i bring
this up because one of the things i've
experienced in the past
is that documents like the 10-year plan
once it's
approved the gore district council
executive staff
regarded as the gospel of gore and
surrounding districts
according to steve perry and associates
the current system may look complex and
i agree it is complex in places
but it does give council flexibility in
applying
rates on hopefully some sort of fair
basis
for where people live rates should be
applied on
a service for services provided not on a
perceived ability to pay
without differentials how can council
rate
a farm at a timer with a capital value
of
say eight million three hundred and
fifteen thousand
and compared and compared to a house in
clyde street
with a capital value of 310 000 on the
same level
there is a lot of positives to the
current system it gives
counsellors and council and executive
staff
enough flexibility to apply targeted
rates
use the uag to spread the rate burden
fairly
and i think it's the fairest for all
and that's really all i wanted to say so
thank you for your time
thank you thank you hamish you've made a
number of uh points
in your submission and it's now over to
councillors if they want to clarify any
of those points
or ask any questions relating to to
those
any counselors like to do that
john just just with um the current
government talking about rating reform
what are your thoughts on on reform and
air area
and okay um i assume counselor guard on
your hinting at
maybe reform or amalgamation of councils
in their local area
our reform in general could uh probably
take a south and it's probably
is going
i know i perhaps um i hope i didn't
upset anyone by attending that meeting
on monday i was there representing the
atomic water scheme
i think it was good you were there thank
you um but
i did pick up on the fact that i can see
that the government are
one are going to push for councils in
their area
to combine i would suggest that
we keep out of invercargill city and
dunedin city
i think gore southland and
and otago would make a really good
efficient rural council it would spread
costs it would minimise administration
costs
minimise the cost of some executive
staff
yeah it could it could be a benefit to
everyone
okay um any other questions
from councillors does not look hamish
thank you
for taking the time to be here today
thank you thank you for the thought that
you've
put in uh to your submission and we'll
take those comments on board and
certainly dwell on them as we make some
deliberations about this time next week
thank you
okay so
we're still ahead of time um so
i notice uh ian ian cubert
and do you would you like to come and
share your thoughts
walk along in and you have
10 minutes
your worship ceo and councillors
i'm here i am a retired electrician
and uh i do a fair bit of walking so
you'll see me around town quite a lot
all the
the streets i've seen you around a lot
lately
you see me around yes you do
right now where do we start
gauze think big projects
the first one the council building
did it need doing did it need doing
second one the library
why didn't we put the roof
on the old library i have here
a 2018 to 2028
gore are we ready and in there there's a
beautiful roof
on oh a beautiful roof on the old
library
and it looks very good that never went
ahead
why that would have been done and dusted
now
the roof done the library done
the third the third thing i've got
is a subject that god
the bridge the bridge
the bridge to me is just a complete
waste of time
we get water from east go
over to the hillbilly there by using
or pumps pipes
so why do we have to build a bridge that
nobody wants or if we have to build a
bridge
we don't have to go to the monstrosity
that has been put forward
one of the things that these three
big projects have taken is leaving us
in heavy debt
the bridge i believe is going to cost
something like
10.8 million the library
has which is not finished yet will be 4
million plus
and it's just something that well
obviously in the council building it was
six million
and it's something that the rate players
have got to fund
haven't we we've got to fund this and
as a rate payer my rates every year
are doing this every year
now in this in this document here
that was put out uh
2018 to the 28th there was a graph here
that said the rates for 2021
will be 4.53
fair enough but what are they going to
be this year
something like 8.2
now will that occur next year
and the year after and the year after
remember us rate payers a lot of
ratepayers as tracer said
uh we have got an agent population here
in goa
it is an aging population and we have
got to keep funding uh you know our race
our pension
is is going down and down and down they
don't
increase our pension by 4.7
every year so it comes out of our
are the savings or the pension
and what i'm saying is is that surely
we have to try and keep the rates
at a reasonable level and at 8.2 percent
is not a reasonable level but in my mind
anyway
the next thing is as they've all been
talking about
is the the waste water and water
on elizabeth street i think is a bad one
but i mean who is going to fund this
i don't want to see pensioners
having to fork out between say seven and
nine thousand
to have their waste water and water
separate storm water separated
and it's a lot for pensioners that is a
real
big slice
so again
i don't know um
right that's what i just won the thing
another question i've got for you
for the for the council is why haven't
we
started this project before now
this project of separating the storm
water
wastewater why are we just starting it
thinking oh better do something about it
why hasn't it been done
years ago i've been here 15 years now in
gore
and it's never been mentioned or it's
been mentioned and passed over or we'll
do it
next time but it's not right
i mean it's come to a head now where
we've got to do it
so i mean we should really have thought
of this thing oh well
we should do this well let's hope it
does
ah um yes
that one i suppose um
a quick one
there's a quick one is the streets of
life program
which i think you've got a meeting
afterwards um
i've i walk these streets every day
and every day i see the same three or
four people
oh i i talk to it's the same couples
every day
you see them walking the streets no
matter what and i do a big area
and we always talk good morning and we
all have a chat
there's never and the people i see
they all say the same thing and it is
not very positive
about the streets life project and when
i
this morning walking past the pocket
parks
i thought well what a disgrace they are
i'm sorry about that but they're a
complete waste of time
and if they get the word go
or they've gone do it by friday because
friday we get the gold guitars here and
the streets are full i should be
i don't mind what they've done in some
of the uh
on eric street there but
you've got to open up brown street
you've got to do echo street
let the traffic flow through
that's it folks thank you for listening
look thank you ian
again you're fairly
clear in your thoughts about what the
council
does what it does wrong from time to
time
so it's open now for questions from
councillors
for clarification anything you might
like to
check in with
doesn't look like it i think you've made
it crystal at this point
ian so thank you uh for your comments we
will be
like everybody else considering these
thoughts over the next week
and make some deliberations this time
next week so thank you
thank you okay look i think we'll um
take a break now for quarterback
and uh and reconvene in um in about 15
minutes
thank you